yet another storm in Washington over one
of president Trump's nominees this time
Jeana hospital under the microscope
ahead of her confirmation hearing on
Wednesday the CIA director nominee
appeared on the hill today to meet with
senators in advance of the hearing
administration sources confirm hospital
was willing to withdraw for
consideration over the controversy about
her role in the CIA's controversial
interrogation program but the White
House is firmly standing behind her she
deserves quick confirmation without
partisan theatrics the bottom line
Acting Director Haspel has an
unparalleled understanding of the CIA
and is the right person to lead it
during these dangerous times she wants
to do everything she can to make sure
the integrity of the CIA remains intact
isn't unnecessarily attacked and if she
felt that her nomination would have been
a problem for that and for the agency
then she wanted to do everything she
could to protect the agency at the same
time she wants to do everything she can
to protect the safety and security of
Americans which is why she is 100%
committed to going through this
confirmation process the president
tweeted his support earlier my highly
respected nominee has come under fire
because she was too tough on terrorists
think of that in these very dangerous
times we have the most qualified person
a woman who Democrats won out because
she is too tough on terror win Gina
even people who used to hold this role
think she's the right fit for the job
with a president who does not always
attach his decisions to the rural world
to data to evidence Gina Haspel is the
one woman I want in that room when
everyone else will be going into
north-south auto Bob and saying you're
right boss
Gina Haspel won't all right Hayden
coming out in strong support of
President Trump CIA nominee Gina
hospital saying in fact this is the
exact person you want in the room and
making the decisions and these tough
times dealing with terror yeah I would
call that a backhanded compliment I mean
it was like we need to have her because
the president's crazy is basically what
he just said
but I always wonder what are the
Democrats wanted a position like this so
they want you know they never want an
adult who do they want it they want dr.
Phil apparently they don't think a woman
could do the job they can do that to
Republicans Republicans can do that back
but this is and we always know this is
the case this is the byproduct of team
sport politics it the other team cannot
make it easy for your nominations to get
through has nothing to do with
qualifications expertise or talent they
just got to do it because you're not on
the same team but the other thing and
that caught the the long-term
consequences of stuff like this you will
be punished in the future for the brave
choices you make in the past so how will
that influence present-day Patriots when
they have to deal with really really
tough choices in the in terms of people
being threatened or there could be a an
impending attack and you have to decide
well am I going to sacrifice my future
and make a decision that could be looked
upon later as illegal or do I just not
do that and just and just make the world
less safe now that's the thing that
scares me and so true Dan so what are
they expecting the Democrats we're gonna
make a choice that perhaps they think is
OK because somebody who's put in charge
of terrorism and making sure that we
keep America safe she's too tough on
terrorists on al-qaeda and all of the
rest think that the president has his
finger on the pulse of where the
American public is on this from the
standpoint of being tough on terror
we've proved we've proven that again and
again but also remember John Brennan who
was a superior to Gina Haskell was
confirmed to be CIA director and he did
not go through this kind of scrutiny and
so the fact that she is under President
Trump does leave a lot of room for
question in terms of the strategy
politically just a moment to talk about
her you know after 9/11 she was one of
the men and women that were asked to do
really tough things she wasn't the
lawyer okay she was the intelligence
operator and the lawyers at the Justice
Department deliberate over all of this
and they say here's where the law is I
can't think of a better way to empower
terrorists than to take our men and
women and intelligence and what Greg
saying basically make them second-guess
themselves when they're like oh should I
can i but I they had the legal clearance
they did really tough things they caught
people like I hadn't I don't come on
person they caught terrorist like Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed who who cut off the head
of Danny Pearl The Wall Street Journal
reporter there were three terrorists who
went through the waterboarding that was
the one in enhanced interrogation
technique that they did not like it is
no longer available to be used unless
this President or this justice partner
this Congress decides to change it but
the other thing if I could just mention
one other point Ron Wyden the senator
from Oregon said why her I mean there's
so many women in national security who
could do this job no actually exactly
her so in 33 years of her career
dedicated to public service she asked to
be transferred for to the
counterintelligence unit she was
transferred on September 11th 2001 that
was her first day on that job and I I
think that they deserved a lot more of
our support than this condemnation
decades later I do think she will be
confirmed and that the Democrats are
choosing a really unfortunate reason to
try to put her through the wringer just
let her get through because she is going
to be confirmed yeah and it's such a
good point that you make because she
should be respected chosen and confirmed
based on the majority of her body of
work three years keeping America safe
protecting this country working so much
of it in an undercover operations and
just add one more thing Brian I know
you're ready to go but I don't usually
like to say this but what it means for
women working in government for her to
stick to it take the support of the
president go forward and be confirmed is
so important she spent 33 years there it
takes a long time for women and
government to get to these positions but
government is where women can really
make a difference in leadership her
going forward
standing tall she has nothing to be
ashamed of everything to be proud of it
means a lot for women behind you coming
up through the ranks if you go through
this confirmation you're absolutely
right and she's got a stand you know
strong and tough on this like she has
for 33 years of a dedicated career
really asking for nothing back in return
and not even in no financial
consideration there because they don't
get paid much they work very hard to
make sacrifices
firstly and for their family Brian she
should be chosen not because she's a
woman because she is the best choice in
candidate for the job remember President
Obama comes in Eric Holder goes first
thing I'm gonna do is go after his
enhanced interrogation and all of a
sudden Lillian Panetta goes wait a
second back off I'm protecting my people
all of a sudden people saying wait a
second you're going after me for doing
something that Justice Department
allowed me to do to stop the next attack
if you read Jose Rodriguezes book you
read with the CIA
men and women did at the time there's no
doubt they stopped the next attack not
only do I hope that she embraces her
role in the black sites and in the
enhanced interrogation I think she
should do it with pride and I think she
should invite people to have this
dialogue I did what I was supposed to do
I'm proud of what I did as an American I
followed the law I'm the I'm very proud
of it after 32 years to get to the point
where I'm deputy now acting if you want
to give me the job go do it if you don't
like what I did you should have stopped
whether you should have not given
allowed us to do the program because it
was signed off by everyone so it comes
down to votes Rand Paul is is you know
he was he was seeing I doubt you as an
eye doctor at the time so he's perfectly
qualified to comment on this so he
doesn't want to vote for her but if Joe
Manchin John tester Joe Donnelly Heidi
Heitkamp and Claire McCaskill have want
any hope of holding on to their seat in
red states they better vote for and for
her to say I don't want to be Ronnie
Jackson on Wednesday and then to have to
run to the CIA to say come on back we're
gonna fight for you it shows me the
White House was slow to back her they
did not get the campaign going
and if Pompeo couldn't get 60 votes
she's saying why do we want to not only
not get the job but ruined my reputation
at the same time I am horrified and I'm
embarrassed but lawmakers who will not
run to her defense right now no no
you're right I mean she should be
celebrated say what a strong outstanding
choice the president is made and she's
willing to continue to serve this
country faithfully despite the efforts
by those to smear her and besmirched our
reputation based on what she did which
was upholding the law those are that's
the law in the books that she stopped
the next attack if she was part of the
black sites and that's a derogation
chief of staff for jose rodriguez women
and young girls growing up should look
up to someone like this to say I can be
and achieve and be anything I want in
life look at the strength of those who
have come before and if I could add one
more thing
all the acting directors back her that's
actor clapper back sir
ten and national television but Panetta
Hayden Morrell who was acting for a
while McLaughlin Porter Goss and Bob
Kerry a Democratic senator backer all
right well let's see if the Senator Rand
Paul and McCaskill will come forward
because he's got a tough tough race
ahead of them I think I should get you
guys pom-poms and you could be like a
cheering it lacks somehow coherence
because you've got 100 military people
who have said we oppose Gina Haskell gee
why would 100 of our American military
personnel oppose Gina hassle when all
the insiders people I know in
intelligence community people who have
been absolutely demonized by the Trump
administration by the way member not
season halt arrest now everybody's a pro
see I Pro and guess what the insiders
love Gina Haspel trust there thinks that
she is competent does her job well but
when you come down to this issue it's
not about having some by everybody on
the inside say yeah we like our fellow
insider
it's about American values and in terms
of American values someone like John
McCain who was tortured says I couldn't
I can't do that Dianne Feinstein who was
definitely a woman and definitely open
to having a woman the first woman run
CIA says the more I read the more
disturbed I am we were she and so was
she during this [ __ ] was happen let me
just finish it right so what you have
here is a situation where a mark short
and Sarah Huckabee Sanders had to go
over to CIA because guess what the
impression is that in a 51/49 Republican
to Democrat Senate right now they're not
the votes to approve Gina house oh you
don't have Rand Paul you don't have
McCain doesn't mean that doesn't mean
you won't have them standby waiting - L
didn't have those votes I tell you what
and how long did it take him so I think
Gina Haskell doesn't want to go through
that the question is right now whether
or not she can say listen that's in the
past because arguably she's the perfect
person to say you know what that was a
mistake I have been through it and let's
move on I think
tactic out there there's people who
support her who wants her to say what
Wan said no and I think it'd be a big
mistake I don't think she should not
back down
unless she did it did she wink yes it
was a mistake people that are trying to
support someone else and not supporting
her for other different political
ideological this outfit I think you're
missing this is about American values
and you know what we don't torture
people we don't think that interrogation
is fun working with the psychologists
this is good you should think about is
it one of your friends that had a choice
to jump out of a 67 through a four
building or burn alive if you want to
stop the next attack from happening
that's what she had to deal with and she
was one of the people that made it work
she should be see she get a medal and
the knife and the position why we are
able to sleep peacefully at night she
was the one that wasn't being faint of
heart I was making decisions and
participating for 33 long years helping
keep us all safe 9/11 happens I know
about all being safe but here's the
thing it's not only the fact that she's
entire and people were being when one
person was being tortured it's also the
destruction of the tapes and I think
that's what senator Feinstein is saying
hey you know what you can say oh the
lawyers said go right out you've but if
you're a function or if that's all
you're you're not a leader then okay
then there's no the Attorney General
comes in Obama asked him please can you
do this review does review decline to
prosecute correct I can I'd something
like what point does the legal system or
the Justice Department or who gets the
final word the final word was we are not
going to punish people from the prior
administration that was does she not
fall into that category not in this
instance disliking her at the top job at
CIA that reflects our values you're
gonna go torture people you don't know
few ways of course by the way proof that
she participated in the enhanced
interrogation of any
detainee at all was there
she stopped myriad of attacks Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed said it myself put the
time and to do the research for the
people to do it they're the ones who
said this stopped and that sent a
message do you know you did not
personally participate present now my
point is the escape hatch in this
argument is always it does not reflect
our values that is ate and emotional
feeling it's not based on any fact
morals the facts are our values survived
because of our willingness to try and
prevent the evil actions of people who
want to destroy the world that reflects
our values to say oh this is beneath us
please we fought Wars we did bad things
in wars to preserve our freedoms there
our values are that the willingness to
protect this country yeah we have a
large military and we do it but we don't
part of the people you would feel you
got to follow the law on this this is
legal this was vetted this was something
that was approved that was on the books
she did not commit any crimes she did
not engage in any kind of misconduct
whatsoever
she followed the law